Esta es una mañana que se llama
tranquila en bakmuda a pesar de todo lo
que estamos oyendo tanto disparos de
entrada como de salida los
enfrentamientos están en diferentes
partes alrededor de la ciudad pero
especialmente en Soledad una población
que está a menos de siete ocho
kilómetros de aquí Ahí es donde se
centran en este momento la mayor parte
de enfrentamientos las fuerzas rusas
especialmente esa fuerza Wagner
paramilitar la clamó su Victoria días
atrás sin embargo las fuerzas ucranianas
dicen que todavía tienen presencia y
siguen luchando por el control de la
ciudad aquí nos contaban que esta mañana
hubo fuertes enfrentamientos o sea
solamente pocos kilómetros de este lugar
donde nos encontramos que está muy cerca
del río y de uno de los puentes que hace
la división con estas fuerzas que luchan
por la ciudad nieva hace muchísimo frío
sin embargo tranquilidad por ejemplo nos
llevó a ver esta mañana a muchísimas
personas que todavía viven en los
sótanos en los pequeños mercados que se
crean en estos momentos de tranquilidad
van con sus carritos compran comida
recogen lo que hay de ayuda humanitaria
y vuelven a encerrarse en esta ciudad
que es en este momento y ya desde hace
semanas y meses el centro de las grandes
luchas aquí en esta Guerra de Ucrania se
ha convertido en una obsesión para las
fuerzas de Moscú que quieren obtener su
Control pero también es un lugar
estratégico para las fuerzas ucranianas
que han invertido muchísimos hombres y
muchísimos eh eh esfuerzo por mantener
su control